one guys private message on mys to
selected individuals insallah you guys
have been fantastic and you have been
donating every single one of you guys says we
want to hit 250,000 today we're only
34,000 away with our donors who are
donating and you guys inshallah on
WhatsApp if you know anyone that can
help insallah this year this
project is about to go global weve gone
all the way around UK Europe we reach
Latin America we printed 15,000  of
guided prim which is in seven different
languages
got UK Europe and China Latin America
we have got increasing the amount of
sals that we
have so much that you know the Japanese
sister who actually accepted Islam she's
going to be learning how to sal through
us through our team and get inallah and
weve got our saling and there's so much
to go inallah so we want to h 250,000
today whatever you can donate and if you
know anyone insallah that can donate
brothers and sisters it  will help us to
reach insallah we are teaching
100,000 people,
God willing. God
Almighty and whatever good you spend, God is All-Knowing of it.
God Almighty, peace and blessings be upon him, said:
Take from their wealth a
charity by which you purify and sanctify them, and pray for them, for
your prayers are a comfort to them. God
Almighty, charity.
[Music]
Do other
people. Peace and blessings be upon him.
Protect them from the Fire. And if you cannot, then a
kind word. A kind word. May God bless
you.
Peace be upon you and God's mercy and blessings.
Peace be upon you and God's mercy